[Applause]
[Applause]
first the first thing that I've gotta
say and I'm so grateful especially those
we're here at 5:00 a.m. setting up these
signs those of you who've been knocking
on doors for the last seven months in
Iowa making phone calls inviting people
in to their own democracy and making
sure that they have a voice that they
can stand up that they can be counted
those of you who came from other states
to be with us here today he'd been there
for the entire distance from before
there was a campaign for the presidency
I just want you to know how much I love
you and how grateful I am for you and
how proud I am to be in this with you I
also want to address those who could not
be with us here today
in Des Moines who are watching from home
I want to say to Amy who's in El Paso
right now with Ulysses and Molly and
Henry and could not be with us today
this is the decision that we made so
recently and so reluctantly that she
can't be here in person and she just
texted me and she said I wish I was
there and I said Amy you are here and
everyone who is not physically here
who's been part of this campaign
reason that we ran in the first place
here here with us right now he will
always be with us and I will always be
with you this is a campaign that has
prided itself on seeing things clearly
and when speaking honestly and acting
decisively we have to clearly see at
this point that we do not have the means
to pursue this campaign successfully and
that my service will not be as a
candidate nor as a nominee of this party
for the presidency I entered this
campaign because I believed that we had
the ability to bring together it very
divided and highly polarized country in
the face of the greatest set of
challenges that we have ever known and
the chief amongst those challenges is
the fear that grips so much of America
today the fear that our current
president wants us to feel about one
another and about ourselves as a country
the very real fear the part too many
live under day in and day out and the
fear in public life too often to do the
right thing because it may go against
the political wisdom or the foils or the
politics or prospects in the next
election but here is what we have all
done and what we all decided to do we
chose in the face of that to be unafraid
to say what needed to be said to call
things by their right name and to go
everywhere especially those places that
have been counted out or forgotten or
taken for granted to bring everyone in
to the solutions
these challenges and our democracy as it
faces the test of all tests we were the
first presidential campaign to propose
an ambitious plan to confront climate
change before it is too late we're the
first campaigns propose the boldest set
of solutions to the epidemic of gun
violence in this country unafraid to
confront the conventional wisdom it was
possible to say in the public sphere for
so many years and decades before this
one all of us you've made this possible
and made the change that our country and
especially our kids deserve possible we
talked about and we elevated the plight
and the promise of immigrants and asylum
seekers and refugees and the communities
in which they lived
including Des Moines Iowa and in El Paso
Texas nothing to be afraid of everything
to celebrate an example for the rest of
this country about who we are at our
best also together connecting the dots
to help this country come to the
conclusion about the costs and the
consequences of Donald Trump the racism
foundational endemic systemic in America
brought out in the open during this
administration and directed along with a
violence that is unknown in any other
country on this planet here where we
lose 40,000 of our fellow Americans
every single year to gun violence he
directed that at the most vulnerable and
the most defenseless on august 3rd of
this year
two killed in El Paso Texas we help this
country to understand that that did not
happen by accident but instead by design
and each one of us knowing that going
forward will be culpable in this
violence and in this racism unless each
of us stand up to be counted stand up
against this president stand up for the
best interests of this country and have
the political courage to do what is
necessary while there is still time to
act every single one of you should be
proud of your ability to do that to
change the conversation in this country
to bring the wisdom the genius the
intelligence of all of our fellow
Americans regardless of what party they
belong to where they live who they love
to whom they pray how many generations
they've been in this country or whether
they just showed up today if you're here
right now you're in the right place if
you're in America you will be part of
our success and every single one of us
here and all of you are part of this
campaign made this happen though this is
the end of this campaign we are right in
the middle of this fight I will do
everything that I can to support the
eventual nominee of this party with
everything that I've got and I encourage
every single one of you to do the same I
will still be part of all the causes
that brought us here together in the
first place whether it is ending gun
violence or confronting climate change
before it is too late or addressing the
structural racism in America or making
sure this economy works for every single
one of us I will still be part of the
fight and so will you because I know
that you are not
here and I know that you are not part of
this campaign for me or for this party
but for this country that we love so
much for this country which we are going
to come through for now at its defining
moments of truth and I will tell you
this the very last place that I got to
visit before being here in Des Moines as
a candidate just as an American as a
human being
this Newtown Connecticut and I listened
to a community and two families who had
been through so much and today almost
seven years later show so much courage
and give us an example for the way
forward not just when it comes to safety
in our schools or against the gun
violence that we see too too often in
this country but how we as Americans can
make it and so many of the best ideas
and so much of the courage in that room
came from the very youngest among us
including those who are too young to
vote and that is how it has always been
in this country at these defining
moments of truth it is the very youngest
in World War two
the 17 and 18 and 19 year olds landing
at Normandy on the 6th of June 1944 to
make this country and this world safe
for democracy on the 1st of February
1964 students from North Carolina A&T
sitting down at the lunch counter at
that Woolworths in Greensboro North
Carolina and having the audacity and the
courage to order a cup of coffee and
after they were denied because of the
color of their skin showing up every day
thereafter until finally they integrated
that lunch counter helped to shock the
conscience of this country inspired
other young people around America and
produced the Civil Rights Act of 1964
the Voting Rights Act of 1965 those
young students at
Kent State in 1970 who knew that we
should not be at war in Vietnam and
stood up against that and stood in the
line of fire four of them giving their
lives it has always been the young
people of this country willing to serve
to struggle to sacrifice who have
brought us to our senses and brought us
to a better place than we would have
been otherwise let us allow ourselves to
be inspired and led by them right now at
this moment let us ensure that each one
of us does all that we can to make sure
that we are worthy of them and the
generations that follow that is why we
are in this fight that's why I will stay
in this fight in whatever capacity I can
and why I'm so grateful that I was in
this fight as a candidate with you I
want to tell you from the very bottom of
my heart how grateful I am how well
served I was by the members of this team
those those who never drew a paycheck
and at their own expense traveled this
country brought other people in the lead
in this campaign and in this country and
made sure through the courage of their
convictions and their willingness to act
on them this country can realize its
potential in its promise this has been
the honor of my lifetime I love you all
and I know that I'll be seeing you down
the road thank you so much
[Applause]